talking about having the life you've
been with Goldie Hawn for 34 years now
that's what I've had the good luck I'm
curious when when you guys when did you
first meet
we actually we've kind of met twice we
met in 1966 on a Disney picture one of
the only genuine original family band I
was about 16 she was a young dancer was
her first movie right and then the the
time that we met and got together that
was in 1983 mm-hmm on swing shift okay
so you met her for the first time what
uh not when you went in for an audit
just like a reading uh like yeah I was
gonna go in to meet her to do the movie
to get the job or not yeah yeah
so wait that's weird so you meet her did
you know right away that you had
chemistry in this situation well ours is
a little strange I mean the night before
that my dad and I had been out now my
dad is a heavy drinker right yeah when
you go out with my dad it can be a long
night and that one was and I was four
o'clock in the morning or something I
said hey Dad I gotta get to sleep
because I got an interview in the
morning I got to go to so I got up early
to make sure that I was there and they
knew I was there right so I told the
secretary look I'm early I'm just gonna
go sit in the corner there for a little
bit and she's ready just yawns ready to
meet ya wake me up so I was severely
hungover in other words and and door
opens and I didn't I you know I didn't
know Goldie at all outside of having
worked with her and it was many years
before and I just didn't have in my mind
what I was gonna see and she had a she
had a great body and so I died the first
thing came out I just I said man you got
a great figure and I and it kind of came
out quickly and I could have been wrong
and she said thank you yeah and then I
watched her take one hat off and put
another hat on and she said okay let's
talk about this you know it's crazy you
do that and it's cool and you end up
with her for 34 years
I have done that many times in my life
and it's I get maced run again if they
completely I'm like you got a great
figure it's a totally different
situation
you